[音楽]
皆さんこんにちは
竹内一郎と申します僕は大学や研究所で
AIの研究をしてます
テッドのTはテクノロジーということなん
ですが今日はAIがテクノロジーをどの
ように変えていくかということを皆さんと
一緒に考えたいと思いますどうぞよろしく
お願いします
早速ですがAIというとチャットGPT
っていうのを聞いたことがある人がいると
思うんですがこの中でチャットGPTを
使ってみたことがある方どれぐらい見え
ますでしょうか
ちらほら手が上がりますね半々ぐらい
でしょうか
チャットGPT今画面に映ってますがこれ
はAIについて150文字で説明して
くださいというふうにお願いするとこんな
文章を書いてくれます
ちゃんとこうAIっていうのが何かって
ことをコンパクトにきれいにまとめてくれ
てますねこれは文章を生成してくれるAI
ということなので
精製AIという風に呼ばれてます
生成AIはですね文章を作成してくれる
だけじゃなくて例えば次は
画像を生成する
画像生成AIっていうもの
ですこの中には大学生の方たくさん見える
と思うんですが今お願いしたのは大学生の
生活を漫画っぽく書いてくださいっていう
絵を書いてくださいと言ったら今AIが
こういう絵を書いてくれるんですねこう
いうのを画像を生成AIという風に言い
ます
こういう風にですね何か新しいことをAI
が生成してくれるっていう技術はですね
もうありとあらゆるところに
波及していくであろうというふうに言われ
ていて社会を変えていくという風に考え
られていますこれ勝手に200年後の歴史
の教科書はこんな感じになるんじゃないか
と僕が考えて書いたものなんですが皆さん
ちょっと昔勉強した
歴史の教科書で18世紀後半にはなんか
蒸気機関が開発されてで機械化自動化が
起こって世の中が変わったみたいな話が
ありましたね今は
21世紀の前半ですがおそらく200年後
の教科書には皆さんがこの生きている今
ですねこれがなんとか革命AI革命かも
しれませんが違う言葉かもしれません
ただこの21世紀の前半によってAI特に
精製Iっていうものが出てきたことで
世の中が大きく変わるとで大きく変わ
るっていうのはどういうことかっていうと
これまでの常識が非常識になってこれまで
非常識だったことが常識になるとこういう
ことが起こるだろうというふうに言われて
いるわけです
僕はですねAIっていうものによって
サイエンスやテクノロジーをどうやって
変えていくかっていうことをいろんな人と
協力しながら
研究したり
教育したりということをやっていますで
サイエンスの研究ってなんかちょっと難し
そうだなと思うかもしれないのでちょっと
例を挙げてみましょう
今もマスクをかけて見える方が見えますが
コロナウイルスの薬を作るということに
関して世界中の研究者がですね
研究してますでこの薬を作るというのは
どういうことかっていうことなんですけど
薬っていうのはですねえっと化合物化合物
っていうとちょっとなんかややこしそう
ですがなんかいろんなタイプの原子ここ色
で書いてありますがいろんなタイプの原子
がいろんなつながり方をしてるものこう
いうものの中で一番コロナウイルスに効果
のあるものを見つけるということが
研究の一つの流れになりますいろんな原子
があっていろんなつながり方があるので
ありとあらゆる化合物っていうのが存在
するわけですねその中で本当にいいものを
見つけるこんなのが研究の例になります
僕自身はですね
コロナウイルスの
薬ではないんですが
バイオスティミュラントって言って
農作物
農作物に対する
薬のようなものですねそういうものを作ろ
うってことをいろんな人と一緒に研究して
ますで農作物の薬って言うとみんな農薬
じゃないかと思うかもしれませんけど今の
農薬っていうのはなかなか環境に良くない
面があって本当に環境に優しく
農作物を
栽培を促進してくれるようなそういうもの
を作れないかっていうところにAIを活用
するということをやってますこのBIOS
っていうのもさっきのコロナウイルスの薬
と同じでいろんな原子がいろんなつながり
方をしているとそういう化合物をいかに
見つけるかというようなことになります
で
科学研究
技術開発って一体どうやって行われるの
かっていうことなんですけどなんか研究者
があります僕も研究者の圧縮でですがまず
最初にですね
研究対象に対して何か仮説を立てるんです
ねもしかしたらこういうような化合物が
バイオスティミュラントにいいんじゃない
かっていう仮説を立てますそしたらですね
次はその
論文を読んだりとかいろいろ本で調査し
たりしてその仮説を評価します
いよいよその仮説が有望だってなったら次
は実験をするんですね本当にその仮説その
化合物が良いかっていうことの実験をし
ます
そうするとその実験データからいろんな
知識が得られてでさらにそれが新しい仮説
につながるとこのループをですね
繰り返すことこれが
科学研究の営みそのものなんですね
僕自身の研究はですねこの科学研究の営み
全体をAIによって自動化してしまおうと
いうことです今
研究者が映ってましたがこれがAIに
変わるんですねでもちろんAIが勝手に
なんかやるって言うんじゃなくて
研究者は本当にアイデアを出すとで
アイデアを出すとですねAIが
研究してくれるとそんな未来像を書いて
研究をしてますで
仮説生成ってあったんですが最初チャット
GPTっていうのは生成AIだっていう話
をしましたねだから生成案によってなんか
こういう化合物がいいんじゃないかって
ことを提案してくれるとそれが
仮説生成をAIで行うということになり
ます
今はですね
研究者がこのものがいいんじゃないかと
思ったら関連する論文を頑張って読んで
評価するんですけど1日どんだけ頑張って
も10本ぐらいの論文しか読めないんです
けどAIはですね100本でも1000本
でも論文読めるんですねですから評価って
いうのもできるようになるしいざ実験に
なるとですねAIが入っているロボットっ
ていうのが自動的に実験を行うようになる
とまあそういう世界がもうすぐ来るだろう
と言われてますで実験結果を分析して知識
を得るというAIもあって
このループがAIによって実現できるとだ
から
研究者
技術者の主な仕事っていうのはいかに良い
アイデアを考えるかっていうところに
フォーカスできるとまあそういう未来とが
起こるんじゃないかと思ってます
でこのAIっていうもの皆さん言葉だけお
聞きになって一体何だって思う方多いと
思うのでちょっと紹介しておきましょう
AIにはですね予測AIと
精製AIというものがありますどちらも
ですね
ニューラルネットワークもしかしたらこの
言葉を聞きになったことある人いるかも
しれないんですが
ニューラルネットワークというもので出て
きますこのニューラルネットワークの
ニューラルっていうのは何かっていうと
ニューロンニューロン神経細胞皆さんの脳
の中には神経細胞がすごい数たくさん入っ
てますが神経細胞のことを英語で
ニューロンと言います
昔AIの研究者はですね知的な
コンピューターを作ろうというところから
始まったんですがその時にですねじゃあ人
はどうやって知的な計算をしているの
かっていうところからまず考え始めたん
ですねそうすると
脳の中で神経細胞同士がこうお互いに電気
信号を送りあってそれで知的な活動が行わ
れているということなのでじゃあそれを
実現するようなコンピュータを作ってやれ
ばいいんじゃないかとこれが人工知能研究
の始まりだったわけです
で下に書いてあるものこれあのなんか丸
っていうのが1個1個の神経細胞
ニューロンでそれが細い線や太い線で
つながってますねこれがニューラルネット
ワークっていうもので今のAIの中には
ですねこのすごい
膨大な数の
ニューロンがつながったようなそういう
ものがコンピューターの中に入って例えば
チャットGPTとかができてるとそういう
状況です
重要なことはですね
ニューラルネットワークすなわちAIって
いうのはデータから学習するものなんです
ね
インターネットワークっていうのはですね
最初は何もできないんだけどデータから
学習しますちょっとイメージするために
ですね
ニューラルネットワークをこれから勉強
する学習する生徒だと思ってデータデー
タっていうのはこう例えばWeb空間上の
膨大なデータとかですねそれを教師と思い
ましょうで例えば何かこの
ニューラルネットワークがこう何も知ら
なかったんだけど足し算をできるように
学習したいというのはどういう感じでやる
かっていうと最初は生徒はですね何も知ら
ないから2と7っていうのがにら
ネットワークに入ってきた時に2+7は
本当は9なんだけど6ですかって間違える
わけですねその時データである教師が
いやいやこれはQですよっていう風に
間違いを指摘してくれてこれをこう
フィードバックします
そうするとですね
丸を結んでいる線がちょっと
太くなったのわかると思うんですがこれが
生徒がちょっとだけ
賢くなったものこういうことをやるんです
ねさらにまた別の問題3+5はって言って
今回はちょっと
賢くなったので8って答えてで教師の方が
合ってますよとそうするとまたその情報が
ニューラネットワークにフィードバック
すると
これをですねすごいデータの数に対して
学習すると自然に足し算をするとで
チャットGPTっていうのはもっとすごい
ことができるわけですがこういう風にして
ですね今のAIっていうのはできてます
すなわちデータというのがあってそこから
学習するとこれが今のAIのポイントに
なってます
でこれさっきあの僕がいろんな人と
取り組んでるっていう
バイオスティミュラントという話なんです
が例えばですねbiostミミラントに
対して予測AIを行うっていうのはですね
こういう化合物が例えば30点ぐらい
良かったですよとかこういう化合物が60
点ぐらいだったですよとかこういうのが
20点でしたよとこういうことをですね
学習させるとなんか新しい化合物を提案し
た時にあこれは55点ぐらいかなとかって
ことを予測してくれるとこういうのが予測
AIなんですね
じゃあですね
精製AIで例えば今僕らは何をしたい
かっていうとですねなんか2つ
biostmentの候補の化合物があっ
て一方はすごい聞くんだけど環境に
ちょっと良くないとでもう一方は
効き目はイマイチなんだけど環境には
優しいとそうするとですね僕らとしては
それを足して2で割ったようなものを作り
たいわけですねでもまあ皆さん
こうなんかこういうのの足し算とか割り算
って多分勉強したことないと思うんです
けど今はできないんですけどAIではです
ねこういうことができつつあります例えば
これ人の顔の画像でこの4名は世の中に
実在する人なんですけど今AIにはですね
この人とこの人を足して2で割ったような
人はどんな人ですかって言ったらこの右側
の絵ですねこれはAIが作ってくれると
いうことですこれと同じようなことをです
ねAIにやらせるわけです
でここでもニューラルネットワーク使うん
ですねちょっとややこしいですがこの
ニューラルネットワークではある化合物を
入れるとガガガガガッと計算してまた同じ
化合物を出してくれるある化合物を入れる
と画角がっと計算して同じ化合物を出して
くれるとそういうことをですねこの
ニューラネットワークに学習させますこれ
なんか無意味なことやってるような気がし
ますねただですねちょっと考えていただく
となんかこういう形してました
化合物が入ってなんか5個になって4個に
なって2個になって4個になって5個に
なってまた化合物が出てくるとこういう風
な形になってるのがわかると思いますそう
するとですねこの真ん中のところ2個の
ものを例えば横軸に1個目のニューロン
縦軸に2個目のニューロンを取るとこの2
次元の空間の中の1点っていうのがですね
なんか化合物に対応しててまた別の一点が
ある化合物に対応しているとこういうこと
になります今の生成AIっていうのがやっ
てるのはこういう風に作った空間の中から
例えば足して2で割るんだったら真ん中の
点を考えてそれに対応する化合物を生成
するとちょっと難しく感じるかもしれませ
んがこういうことをニューラル
ネットワークを使ってやって
るっていうのが今の生成AIの仕組みに
なります
でこれ先ほどお見せしました今日は
仮説生成っていうところにAIをいかに
使うかってお話をしましたが
仮説の評価実験検証知識発見いろんな
ところでですねAIというのが使われる
ようになります
で今日の僕のトークのタイトルは物理の
時代からデータの時代へとなんかちょっと
よくわからないなというふうに思った方
いると思うんですけど今までこう皆さんが
小学校中学校高校大学と勉強してきたして
きている時に基本的にはですね皆さん
なんか複雑なものなんだけど一個一個分解
してその仕組みを知るとそういうことが
できればそのものを理解して誰しもがです
ね例えばあのなんかその仕組みがわかっ
てるものに関しては例えば自動化できたり
とか理解できたりするとそういうことでし
た
でですねこうなんか皆さんがすごい良い
アイディアがあってそのアイデアがですね
ステップ1ステップにステップ3ステップ
4ステップ5っていう風に5つのステップ
のことが実現できたら皆さんの素晴らしい
アイデアが実現できるとそんなアイデアを
思いついたとしましょう
今までの時代はですね例えばステップ1に
関しては仕組みが分かってるから自動化し
たりとか
理解したりできるステップにもできる
ステップ4もできるでもですねステップ3
っていうのはまだ複雑すぎて仕組みが
分かってないとステップ5もそんなような
状況だったとしましょうそうするとですね
そこはいかに良いアイデアがあったとして
も
専門家の人とかですねあるいはこうなんか
ノウハウを持ってる人とかそういう人じゃ
ないとそのアイデアを実現できなかった
わけですね
ただ今AIっていうのはどういうもの
かっていう時にデータから学習するって
いうことを言いました
そうするとですね何ができるかっていうと
仕組みがわからなくてもその仕組みが
わからないものからデータを取ってきて
そのデータを使ってAIを学習することが
できれば今まで仕組みがわからなくて
専門家に頼らざるを得なかったところって
いうのも自分で実現したりとかあるいは
自動化したりということができるように
なってまあステップ1からステップ5の
アイデアをですね良いアイデアだったら
それが実現できるようになるということ
です
まあざっくりとこう言ってしまうとこの
真ん中の青っぽいところこれは今まで皆
さんがこうできてたことなんですね仕組み
仕組みっていうのはものの通りということ
で物理そのものなんですがそれが分かって
いることだったらこう実現できたんですが
今AIっていうのはデータさえとってそれ
を学習することさえできればまあ
理解したりとか自動化したりできるので
できることっていうのがすごく広がった
わけですねですからこれからはアイディア
があればいろんなことが実現できるという
ことが可能になっているとそういう時代に
皆さんは来ているということが僕がこの
トークで最も伝えたいメッセージになり
ます
これ先ほど200年後の歴史の教科書勝手
に僕が書きましたが
18世紀の後半の産業革命に
相当するような事っていうのが今皆さんの
この
場で起こっているというのが現状だと思い
ます最初にあのチャットGPT使ったこと
があるかないかみたいなことをお聞きし
ましたがまあ使ったことない人もですね
ぜひこれあの僕はサイエンスやって
テクノロジーの話をしましたがありと
あらゆる分野でAIによって何かが変わっ
てきますですからまずこうなんかチャット
GPTを使ってみることから始めてもいい
んですがまあAIが自分が取り組んでいる
ことに対して何を変えるのかということを
ぜひ考えてみて
でできれば使ってみるとそういうところ
からですね皆さんの可能性を広げて
いただけるのがいいんじゃないかなという
ふうに思います
これで僕のトーク終了ですどうもご清聴
ありがとうございました
[拍手]